depuis maintenant un an et demi le shift
project s'est lancée dans la conception
de ce que nous appelons le plan de
transformation de l'économie française
ou ptf quand on l'appelle par son petit
nom il s'agit en gros d'essayer de
comprendre ce que cela signifie pour les
divers secteurs de l'économie de notre
pays de se mettre en conformité avec la
trajectoire de baisse des émissions qui
est la contrepartie logique de l'accord
de paris que notre pays à signer et
ratifier
il s'agit donc de mettre l'ensemble de
nos activités productives en conformité
avec une baisse annuelle des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre dans le monde de
l'ordre de 5% ce qui est absolument
considérable puisque trois fois sur le
dernier siècle les trois fois seulement
une baisse de cette nature a été
observée dans le monde en 1932 en 1945
on imagine la cause et en 2020 à cause
du co lead et il faut répéter ça tous
les ans si nous voulons respecter la
limite de 2 degrés de hausse de la
température planétaire et toutes les
conséquences qui vont avec nous avons
décidé pour faire ce plan de
transformation de l'économie française
de commencer par résonner physique
puisque le problème à traiter et
physique
quinze secteurs qui représentent soit
des pans de l'économie soit des usages
et pour ses quinze secteurs nous nous
intéressons à que doivent faire les gens
et avec quelles ressources si on veut
que les émissions baisse à la bonne
vitesse donc nous avons commencé par
avoir un raisonnement physique par
exemple si on veut que 20% de la
population se déplace à vélo plutôt
qu'en voiture
combien il faut de gens pour fabriquer
les vélos pour rendre les vélos pour
entretenir les vélos pour réparer les
vélos etc c'est ça l'esprit du plan de
transformation de l'économie française
c'est de commencer par résonner sur les
grandeurs physiques en décidant que
l'argent on n'en parlerait plus tard une
fois qu'on aurait compris comment le
système doit s'organiser c'est à viser
délibérément opérationnel c'est à dire
que dans chaque secteur nous
réfléchissons à des mesures que le
prochain président peut prendre la
prochaine présidente peut prendre dès
son entrée en mandats et des mesures qui
sont pour l'essentiel à sa main c'est à
dire qui ne dépendent pas ou pas trop
d'un cadre européen ou mondial il est
bien évident que nous ne sommes pas les
premiers à réfléchir à la manière
faire des choses qui soient pertinentes
en ce qui concerne la baisse des
émissions mais nous pensons quand même
que nous avons quelques particularités
dans ce plan que nous sommes en train de
mettre au point le premier c'est qu'il
est pensé pour l'essentiel par des gens
qui viennent du secteur économique
l'essentiel les chefs de projet au shift
des salariés du shift ou des shifter qui
nous aident sont des gens qui ont un
ancrage dans le monde économique souvent
dans le monde de l'entreprise qui est
probablement une singularité dans le
monde des ong la deuxième chose c'est
que nous avons un focus et une attention
particulière sur l'emploi dans les
sondages ou dans les consultations plus
exactement que nous avons pu effectuer
quoique imparfaite au sein du chip
project il apparaît que l'une des causes
de blocage majeur quand il s'agit de
tout changer c'est la crainte de perdre
son emploi ce qui était un motif est
évidemment parfaitement légitime et donc
un des chantiers du ppf consiste à
essayer de comprendre les
transformations sur l'emploi en rentrant
raisonnablement dans le détail de ce qui
serait la contrepartie des modifications
que nous imaginons voilà tout ça donne
évidemment 15 x 100 pages
c'est à dire un peu de littérature pour
meubler vos insomnies mais l'économie
s'est beaucoup de gens qui font beaucoup
de choses très différentes donc nous
pensons que c'est utile d'aller à ce
degré de détail pour commencer à faire
des propositions qui soient un peu
articulée
j'espère que ce travail vous intéressera
et nous espérons nous en tout cas qu'il
intéressera à peu près tout le monde
dans ce pays car le monde politique ne
s'intéressera à cette manière de voir
les choses qu'à partir du moment où dans
la société civile un nombre suffisamment
important considérons que c'est une
bonne manière d'entrer dans le débat de
quoi faire plus tard
[Musique]